allez les chéris bonsoir à tous
regardez-moi je peux plus les voir
regardez regardez ils ont froid ils ont
chaud une fatigue ils ont toujours
quelque chose je peux plus les voir
allez regardez il y a un zèbre l'autre
il va tous les jours chez le coiffeur
l'autre on dirait une pistache elle a
toujours un truc une fois c'est les
dents une fois c'est le coup une fois
c'est mon cul l'autre c'est pas plus
qu'il est l'autre qui fait des millions
de merde j'ai vu le 6 à 7 c'est un
rendez-vous de débile
Bernard Montiel on sait même pas ce
qu'il fait et l'autre en tout comprend
plus on dirait la gaffe allez tais-toi
allez bon bah merci en tout cas vous
voyez que je suis une bonne humeur merci
les chéris d'être là
je me demande comment service les chéris
je vais aller dans la rue ouvrez-moi ça
je vais leur dire qu'il me sort de là je
peux plus voir regarde-moi ça
regarde-moi ça regardez-moi ça
regardez-moi ça attends regardez on
dirait la vache qui
Rita regardez regardez regardez regardez
je vais me barrer je vais me barrer dans
la rue ouvre-moi
ouvre-moi
ouvre-moi on
doit empêche je te jure sur la tête de
ma mère
je te jure sur la tête de ma mère
pour sortir les gars c'est incroyable
non mais franchement mais quoi donc il
faut qu'il y a un mec qui vienne pour
ouvrir alors on a pris quelque chose oui
il faut un mec qui viennent pour ouvrir
c'est-à-dire je peux pas sortir c'est à
dire que je suis enfermé dans ma propre
maison voilà ce qui se passe voilà ce
qui se passe hein non mais c'est
incroyable regardez ça va
oh enfin libre
enfin libre voilà merci
délivrée on se promène
acheter une baguette
voilà donc il y a des gens sympas voilà
qui habitent par là et l'immeuble là il
y a un petit truc une petite boucherie
là il y a Mokhtar en Ramadan encore
pendant une semaine à mon chéri 5 jours
bah écoute je te rajoute 2 jours c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau sinon voilà il y a
des gens sympas ça va mon chéri
tranquille ouais super j'ai envie de me
promener avec les téléspectateurs on
peut aller jusqu'où viens on va faire un
test on va voir jusqu'où on peut aller
voir ce qu'on peut aller bonjour ça va
bien ça va tranquille ouais super
ça
on va aller au maximum c'est quoi donc
ça c'est maximum ce que tu me vois là et
là et là tu me vois là tu me vois là
encore tu me vois là
il y a plus de câbles et Ben et ouais
mais ouais même s'il y a plus de calme
il me voit encore ah oui
regarde et là tu me vois là et là
et là tu me vois là et là encore là
toujours vas-y tu me dis quand tu me
vois plus tu me vois là toujours c'est
bon ouais là
ouais c'est bon
et là là vas-y je vais essayer de te
perdre je vais essayer de me essayer de
voir quand tu me vois plus vas-y regarde
vas-y tu me parles là tu me vois
toujours et là
tu me vois
poulet
[Applaudissements]